[موسيقى]
انا
اهو انا جيت فعلا في
1992 انتم ما تخيلو ان انا جيت ازاي يا
دوبك 10 ايام كنت في مصر ومصر هزت الارض
تحتي كان بتهز كده وانا كنت بذاكر عربي وق
يا
رب الحيطان عملوا كده اللمبه عملت كده
ولات
كده طبعا انا لوحي في البيت روح فين لسه
ما شفتش الجيران لسه ما عرفتش
حد
نزلت جريت من دور الرابعه
تحت
هافيه انا
خوف يدك في جيبي الباسبور ص حصل حاجه و
لازم يب البت
يعني بس الحمد لله لقيت ناس تحت كلهم ما
حصلش
حاجه عرفت على جيران عرفت على ناس
كتير الغريبه بقى ان انا جايه من بلد صغير
كره صغيره في هولندا القريه ده قريب من
بلد كبير اللي فيها جمعه اللي انا عملت
دراسات علشان التربيه والتعليم اشتغلت
كتير مع اطفال عملت دراسات على الاطفال
اللي يندهوا مشاكل في التعليم درست تروق
تعليم وجيت لمصر علشان اعمل ايه م عرفتش
بالظبط هعمل
[موسيقى]
ايه بس الارضيه
هزت جيت للبلد اللي فيها 15 مليون
بشر
اكتشفت بسرعه في اسرى وقت ان الناس هنا
فعلا ناس حلوين جدا جدا جدا لقيت حيلتي
[تصفيق]
يقولوا لي تعالي مش لازم تطبخي لوحدك احنا
ناكل مع بعض كلت الفول كلت
طعميه لغايه النهارده ده الاكل المفضل ل
على
فكره الملوخيه المحشي met
gees
انس
دفي
يسمعوني كنت بعرف اتكلم كلمتين لاثه اربعه
بالعربي هما علموني الخامس والسادس
والعاشر علموني انت على سنقه
عشره ما فهمتش
المعنى انه الحمد لله يعني بفهمها يعني
الناس فعلا حلوين قوي وحسيت ان انا ابدا
اعيش من جديد انا بن تستغل مع الاطفال
اللي ما يعرفوش يتعلموا اووي اللي في مركز
ز خاص زي ما الناس بيقولوا انا مغزو على
فكره لما دخلت البلد وماعرفتش عربي اشتغلت
مع الاطفال دول اللي بيقولوا كلمه كلمتين
وقعدت مهم على الارض لعبت معهم مكعبات مكع
فوق مكعب فوق مكعب هم يقلدوني هم يبصو لي
هم بيضحكوا معايا وانا بضحك معهم لغه
الجسد ما كانش بتفرق احنا كنا بنفهم بعض
وشويه شويه عشان كان في دكتور تخاطب معنا
ههم يتعلموا يتكلموا وانا تعلمت اتكلم
وكده من خلال سنتين انا كنت متقدمه
عنهم طبعا انا رت بيوت كتير عشان المصريين
بيقولوا
تعالي وانا بحب ناس بحب سور ناس بحب اكون
معاهم اعلمت حاجات كتير مرا دي لازم
اقوللكم اه كنت بشرب شاي مع
شختي التليفون بيرن وبنتها بترد تليفون
الو يا طنط فاطمه ايوه ايوه انت ز ماما
ماما طنط فاطمه موجوده بتسال انت موجوده
ولا
لا
لا مش موجوده سنط فاطمه هي مش
موجوده في يوم من ايام قابلت ناس من برا
قهره قالوا لي يوم الجمعه لازم تيجي عندنا
تتغدي عندنا بعد الصلاه تيجي تقفي يند
محطه المترو وانا هاجي واخدك انكل قال
ماشي انا هولنديه ساعه واحده بالضبط واقفه
عند المترو
[تصفيق]
واحده وربع مافيش حده ونص
مافيش يا ممكن ما فهمتش العربي
بتاعته بس الحمد لله الساعه اين الا دقيقه
و
جا
عملوا لي اكل
فظيع الهم بلاس عن الاكل خلينا نكمل اللي
احنا شوفنا
تاني
الله في يوم دخلت الفصل في المركس اللي
انا كنت بشتغل فيها المدرسه واقفه الف
ارنب ب بطه بقول لها انت بتعملي ايه لان
دي حس عربي دلوقتي عربي وتعملي كده اه كان
في اربع واحد ما يتكلمش تاني
[تصفيق]
بيتكلم من
الحكايه انا مش عرف افهم س لغه عربيه وكل
ربع ساعه هي بتحرك مع طفل والثلاثه الباقي
بيبصوا
عليها ليه بتعملي ده علشان دي ما يقدرش
يكتب دي ما يقدرش يقرا دي ما يقدرش يتكلم
كل واحد محتاج حاجه مختلفه من ساعت انا
روحت وقعت مع نفسي وقلت يا رب انا اقدر
اعمل ايه علشان اساعد الاطفال ان هما يقدر
يكونوا مبسطين انهم يقدر يكونوا مشغولين
ان هم يقدر يتعلموا حاجه مع بعض
وفي الحقيقي اللي حصل خلال الفتره دول ان
انا بدي تحس بالمصريين بديت احس بالحياه
بديت احس بالاطفال انا بديت اتحرك ات
ماشيه من جديد انا بديت اتكلم من جديد كل
يوم اتعلمت خم ع كلمات ولما تاخد كده 10
كلمات كل يوم ده 300 في 30 يوم وده في سنه
طبعا كتير ومن هنا خلال سنتين ثلاثه اربعه
انا عرفت اعمل حاجات كتير في
مصر بس قبلت بلد في الحضانه اللي يترش بس
قلت للناس ليه الولد كده قالتلي بصي هو
كان في المدرسه في الثاني
ابتدائي بس احمد مرفوض هو ما يقدرش يقعد و
ال المس بتقول ومن هنا ه قالوا خلي الولد
عندكم احسن بس ليه الولد
براش علشان كانوا بيضربوا كتير اه قلبي
واقفه بنضرب ولد علشان ما يقدرش
يتعلم كملت فكر ازاي اقدر اسعد
الناس من هنا بعد شبو انا رحت
للحضانه وخط شنطه معايا اللي فيها لبن
اللي فيها جبنه اللي فيها صمنه اللي فيها
بقره اه لا ما كانش بقره
فيها دخلت الفاصل وقلت للاطفال انتم
عارفين ده ايه وشافوا كده الزاز اللي فيها
لبن قالوا
لبن كان معانا كوبايات وكل طفل شرب شويه
من اللبن بعدين كنا بنتكلم عن اللون وعن
الطعم
بعدين قتلهم ده ايه لبن يا مس لبن اه
اللبن انت تسمع الاول ايه لما تقول
لبن برافو عليكم وان اسمي ايه ليزا ايوه
ليزا واللبن ده
النفس
صح بعدين سالتهم اللبن جاي منين الحوارت
كملوا كده بقى احنا ك بنتكلم ان الشخص
اللي بيبيع اللبن واللبن اصلا جاي من
البقره وازاي احنا نقدر نعمل تشوكليت ملك
وازي احنا نقدر نعمل شوكولاته وازي احنا
نقدر نعمل بانكيكس كل ب ساع والاطفال
مبسوطين مشغولين هم كانوا بيشموا كانوا
بيشوفوا كانوا
بيتكلموا اليوم بعدين عملنا كده ركن في
الفصل وحطينا كل الحاجات اللي مربوطه
باللبن فيها والاطفال بداوا يشاركوا مع
بعض ان هم يشتروا ويبيعوا كان معهم فلوس
فعلا واحد يشتري واني يبيع وان هو
ياخذ الفلوس اللي هو دفع اللي لازم
ترجعله
الاطفال كانوا مبسوطين
ويتحركوا وبعدين الميس قالت انا عارف كمان
اغنيه انا لبن يا مس قلت لها خلاص نغنيها
كمان احنا كملنا مع بعض العاب كتير علشان
الاطفال اللي عايزين يتعلموا مش ان هم
لازم يتعلموا علشان انا بقول ده لا الطفل
عايز يتعلم هو عايز يكتشف مش كلنا عارفين
ان طفل عايز يمسك كل حاجه لما يكون صغير
هو لازم يحس هو عاييز يحس بكل حاجه وهو
عايز يتحرك هو عايز يعرف ده ايه عشان كده
هو بيعمل
ده الطفل ده بيحب الالعاب ومن هنا لما
احنا بدينا نعلب مع بعض هما بداوا
يتعاونوا مع بعض كانوا بيستنوا دورهم وما
كانش لازم اناس بتقول يلا اقعد هنا استنى
اعمل كذا او كذا لا الاطفال كانوا موتيه
موت الاطفال كانوا بيبصوا في الكتب مع بعض
وكتاب كبير كانت على الارض واتنين لاثه
قاعدين قدام الكتاب واحده بتحكي الثاني
بتسمع الثالث بيسال
كانت حاجه جميله
جدا بعد ما احنا كنا مع بعض في الفصل
واشتغلنا رحنا للجاردن بتاع الحضانه دي
وكانوا بيلعبوا مع بعض وعايز اشورك على
حاجه اللي جوه الطفل البنت صغيره اللي
انتم شايفين
هنا واقفه كده ليه علشان الولد اللي يعد
فوق بيقول انا خايف انا مش قادره انزل وهي
بتقول ما تخافش احنا هنا
صادك ده الاطفال لما تشوف السلوكيات بتاع
الاطفال اطفال نقي اللي امنين مع نفسهم
اللي يجين يكونوا جنب
الاخر وبعدين المنظر بتاع الفصل اللي فيها
40 50 طفل قدام مس اللي بتو اللي بتقف
الاطفال قاعدين وم يتحرك
كوش انا كنت
عزينه اقدر اعمل ايه الاطفال لازم يتعلموا
يكونوا زي ما انا اعلمت ان انا اقدر اكون
في مصر ان انا اقدر اتكلم ان انا اقدر احس
بالاخر ان انا اقدر اكون موجود علشان
اساعد الاطفال لازم يطوروا نفسهم ان هم
يقدروا يكونوا يكونوا شخص مستقل يكونوا
شخص مسؤول يكونوا شخص اللي يحترموا الاخر
يكونوا شخص اللي يعرفوا
حدودهم يكونوا شخص اللي يعرفوا
نفسهم يكونوا على التواصل مع
نفسهم يعرفوا ايه اللي مسموح واللي مش
مسموح مش علشان بابا او ماما او المس
بتقول ده بس علشان في ضمير اللي بتقول دوت
وان هو يتعلمه الفرق بين الخير والشر بين
اللي مفيد واللي مش مفيد
والكبار حوليهم يساعدوهم بس انهم يكتشفوا
دوت ومن
هنا ميدو بقت ابني
ميدو بقت
ولد اللي بيساعد ماما اللي بيقول شكرا
اللي بيقول اتفضل اللي بيقول يا تن ممكن
نساعدك ميدو بقت ولد اللي مهتمه
بالحيوانات الصغيره اللي في الش
بسوسو اللي عندها كتن صغير وي جنب انكل
وبيقعد في الشاره وهو عايز يكون جنبهم
ويحميهم ميدو بقت ولد اللي يروح للسوق
ويشتري حاجه لماما او يشيل الشنطه
لماما او يختار اللي هو بياكل ميدو بقت
الولد اللي في البدايه ما كانش عايز ياكل
خضار بس في الاخر عايز ياكل خضار علشان
يعرف لما
ياكل اسبان هو يكون ولد قوي وما تجوش
امراض ميدو بقت ولد اللي بيروح للمدرسه
ويتعلم حروف
وكلمات وميدو بقت ولد مختلف عن الاطفال
اللي انا شفت قبل ما انا قبلت
ميدو الاطفال التانيين كانوا بيقروا كلمات
كف
ل ميم ب ترم بوته كلمه ايه يا ايه ده
انتين
لب
اه دي ايه لمبه كده تقدر تسمع الكلمه ف
ا
فار لما تقول اصوت
الحرف انت تعرف تستهل كلمات انت تعرف تعمل
البلان ميدو اتعلمت يطور المهارات اللي هو
متاج علشان يقدر يتعلم كلمات يقرا كلمات
يقول كلمات ميدو عايش في مصر ومن هنا
البرنامج ميدو في العالم الحروف طورت
نفسها سنه بعد سنه بعد سنه بعد سنه بالبرك
المصريين اللي كانوا معايا اللي كانوا
بيساعدوني اللي كانوا بي الاقتراحات اللي
كانوا بيكتبوا بالعربي وانا كنت جنبهم
علشان الطريق التعليم تكون شمليه ان احنا
نتحرك نبدا نتكلم نطور اللغه اللغه مش
مجرد ان الطفل يقول كلمات لا ان هو يقول
جمل عن هو يسال عن هو يدور على الحلول
بتاع المشاكل ان هو يطور التفكير النقي
الطفل صغير ده اه الطفل صغير ده هو يقدر
ولما هو يتعود على كل ده وهو صغير هو يعرف
يعمل ده لما يكون
كبير من هنا بقت الدليل بتاع
البرنامج كتاب قد كده يعني 300 صفحه
تخيلوا لما المدرسين يشوفوا ده لاول مره
يقولوا لا البرنامج ده مش
ل بس في نفس الوقت الناس اللي عايزين فعلا
يتعلموا الاطفال حاجه مختلفه ويعيشوا
التحدي يتعلموا حاجه لنفسهم اولا وبعدين
يدر يتعلموا دا الاطفال البرنامج طورت
نفسها مع قصص قصص مصريه باخته جنبها
الدليل طبعا بوسترات
اللي بنستخدم مع الدروس
وقبه اللي فيها كروت فلاش كورت كلمات اللي
هم
يتعلموا كلمات مش بس كلمات الصوره
والكلمات والحروف ده في حدثات طبعا مش
غريبه اي حد بيعمل دوت بس الفكره ان احنا
نتحرك مع بعض على الالعاب وعلى الحركه
واحنا نطور
الطفل كطفل مش بس ان هو يعرف الحروف ويعرف
يكتب دي تميز
البرنامج من هنا في ناس في السعيد في قهره
في الدلتا اللي بيشتغلوا مع البرامج هنا
في قهره مي تعلمني اللي بيشتغلوا مع
الاطفال الشوارع بيستخدموا
البرنامج
والاطفال هناك بيحسوا
بميو ونفسيا وعاطفيا هم يطوروا نفسهم
وبيحبوا
البرنامج الاطفال يتعلموا ان هم يكونوا
الطفل يتعلم
يكون اي بشر محتاج دوت اي بشر محتاج ان هو
يقدر يكون ان هو مع
جسمه يحس بطف متعته
عقله بتركب على العطفه واراده بتاعته تكون
في الاتزان معكل دت لما انا عايزه اتعلم
عقلي تفتح والعطف بتاعتي هتخش لتجاه لما
انا مش عايزه اعلم عقلي
بتقفل
من هنا اقدر اقوللكم
حلمي ممكن كبير بس الحلم يقدر يكون
كبير كل الاطفال المصريون
هيحبوا العربي
هيحبوا يكتبوا ويقرا
بالعربي كل الاطفال المصريون
هيحبوا
بلادنا
ثقافتنا
حياتنا
[تصفيق]
ش هو الحقيقه كان المفروض انه يبقى في
اسئله كتير لها علاقه ازاي الناس تقدر
توصل لمرحله ان هي تعلم اولادها في البيت
وتحب ويحب اللغه العربيه ودي ماساه كبير
جدا ازاي نتخلص منها احنا اسفين عشان
الوقت كبير لكن ليزا هتبقى موجوده اللي
حابب يتواصل معاها ويعرف ازاي يقدر يوصل
للبرنامج انه ده مهم الناس كتير بدات فعلا
تتخلى عن التعليم العادي وتبدا تربي هي
اولادها وتبدا تعلمهم ده فنقدر نتواصل
معاها بعد ما نخلص اليوم وهي هتكون مرحبه
بانها تعرفكم على برنامج
ميدو ممكن حاجه واحده
اقول اشتغل علىك
في في الفيسبوك صفحه ميدو في العالم
الحروف لما تفتح دوت تقدر تلاقيني في اي
وقت
[تصفيق]
في